what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
another episode of pearl daily before I
start don't forget to like the video on
your way in and subscribe to the channel
today we are going to be going over this
week's treachery craziness and
debauchery
so in 2023 we have an all-time low on
marriage there are fewer and fewer
people getting married than ever in all
of history
and the question is why why do we have
this lack of men wanting to get married
why do we have this lack of families in
society why do we have such a me me me
me culture well today the mainstream
media had a very good take where they
just really explained why men and women
are getting together hold a clip king of
I don't want no scrubs
oh this is a real study that was done
through Cornell University that said a
shortage of economically attractive men
there's not enough men who are
economically attractive that may be one
of the reasons why marriage is on the
decline now marriage is at its lowest in
about 150 years in America the marriage
rate now what do they mean by
economically unattractive they said it's
somebody who either doesn't have a
bachelor's degree so that's prospects or
a stable job making forty thousand
dollars a year or more they said one
reason might be education the lead
author said this is a rough quote many
young men today have little to bring to
the marriage bargain and he talked about
how women are going to school more
because they want to you know bring more
to the table to get better jobs I'll say
this this is your sort of Peace of money
advice and this doesn't just come from
me comes from Warren Buffett he says
that the biggest most powerful choice
you will ever make in your life is
choosing the right person for the right
reasons that will make a big difference
in your success
I'm tired of being
panned we are not getting married is
because of the men
really number one in the old days you
would get married under the age of 30.
like this is a very new phenomenon
getting married over the age of 30. and
so typically yeah the guys wouldn't make
forty thousand dollars a year because
they were young and they would work
their way up and you would build with
the guy
um the other question is
um are women wife material nowadays
does the average woman know how to cook
does the average woman know how to clean
was the average woman raised to be a
wife was she taught to serve and Obey
her husband but instead of looking in
the mirror all of these universities all
of these news organizations just
pandered us and as women this [__] does
not help us it does not help us to
constantly be blaming the guys for the
lack of marriage they also do not talk
about how much of a financial risk it is
for a guy to get married ninety percent
of alimony payments go towards women
women get child custody 80 to 90 percent
of the time the entire system is geared
towards women women get the majority of
child support payments and a woman
really can financially ruin a man just
because she feels like it so blaming
this on the men that it's the women not
picking the men over 50 percent of men
are not even looking for dates or
relationships that is really the state
of the modern dating Market in all
honesty guys I don't say this like
because I'm happy about it but a lot of
guys look at the risk of marriage they
look at the quality of the product on
the market and they decide you know the
juice just really isn't worth the
squeeze and you know they've seen a
whole generation of men get absolutely
screwed over by the business of marriage
now how of the women taken this right
I'm sure we just take some constructive
feedback and say let's improve let's get
better let's look inward okay let's see
how the women really take it
what kind of world do we live in where a
normal regular girl cannot find just a
regular guy out here to date
because these guys don't want a real
woman
they want a fantasy
they want
to live in this fake fantasy world they
would rather jack off to some screen to
some robot
rather than actually deal with a real
human being and what comes with that you
know why because it's easier
and I am done I'm done
okay what guys
we gotta stop crying online okay that's
like number one we gotta we gotta stop
doing that as chicks now it's funny
because she says it's easier they would
rather just jack off to the screen or
whatever do the robots
why is it easier because we are so
difficult to deal with as a group let's
look at the quality of the wives and the
mothers on the market what percent of
men have a wife that they can just go
home to they could they could take a
two-day trip and not have to hear about
it
they could say hey I'm going to this
city because I want to and they don't
have to hear anything from their wife
nobody come on what do do the men that
are 50 and 60 years old have a good
review of marriage where they say yes it
was so worth it across the board overall
one in four marriages are sexless
um the second thing is
um I I think it's funny I think a lot of
women project
so
are the men the ones living in delusion
are the men's the ones living in a
fantasy world it's really interesting I
was thinking about this if women are so
we are so addicted to social media what
if men were as addicted to porn as we
are addicted to social media like I
think that would be a good equivalent
and it's like what if they watched so
much that they couldn't even like look
at us in real life but that that's
almost what social media has done to us
like we have seen so much social media
that average men are unattractive to us
what if men had seen so much corn that
average women were unattractive to them
and I know a lot of people will say oh
Pearl that's totally true that's what's
happening I just don't buy it like men
are swiping right half the time on
dating apps they're still wifing up
these fat chicks like I think men have
very realistic standards to be honest I
think it's the women like we're the ones
only swiping right five percent of the
time because social media has just
warped our reality it is completely
changed our reality in society and it's
funny we are so picky
okay this is the funny part so we go we
go through our whole lives right and
we're like that guy's not good enough
that guy's not good enough you know this
weekend I was talking to a 47 year old
woman in a church okay she was 47 years
old and she told me it was good she was
47 and single and like she just needed
to be found by a husband I'm like this
is the delusion we're feeding these
chicks what on Earth
and I asked her I'm like why are you
single
she says I'm too involved in youth group
I'm like what youth group
this doesn't make any sense
is it you're 47 you've had half a
century
but you know whatever
um but women are so this is what we'll
do
we'll spend our youth not getting
married and having a family and then
we'll go to a sperm bank later freeze
our eggs
and
voluntarily choose single motherhood so
a couple months ago I covered a woman
that said she was too good to date a bus
driver at 39 years old would you date a
bus driver
that's the problem
that's a problem because the standards
and requisites and I'm not talking about
him laying on his sofa playing video
games all day I'm not talking about that
but the standards and the criteria that
we use to measure men is off for who we
are as women and who they are in this
Society
and the funny
all she does this woman I'm sure she
makes a lot of money but all she really
does is talking to a microphone like I
think we live in this delusion where
it's like if you get paid a lot of money
for something you feel like you're more
important than the average guy like what
am I doing I'm talking into a microphone
it doesn't make me better than a bus
driver or a plumber like if anything
those jobs are much more needed my job
this like ebony whatever her name is
Ebony Williams her job disappears
tomorrow the world TR will be fine
but the bus drivers stop the plumbers
stop the electricians but this woman
said she was too good for a bus driver I
don't even mind you know women making a
lot of money or do it like I don't I
don't mind any of this but accept what
comes with it and Oprah realized she had
to marry down you know Barbara Walters
realized she had to marry like all of
these women realized that the cost of
success was marrying a guy that was less
economically attractive to them now
that's that's the that's the trade-off
and I have no problem if you're going to
do that but it's a bit disingenuous when
she has this whole parade of oh the bus
drivers aren't working hard enough
what's a harder job talking like come on
what is a harder job talking into a
microphone
or driving a bus
but it's like we live in this delusion
anyway so she comes on TV and says
that she is going to be a single mother
thing really exciting that you are going
to start the fertility process and
um pursue single night single motherhood
now um I feel like you've spoken about
this before so I know it's something you
wanted to do
turns out I now have a known donor I
went through California Cairo Bank
fantastic experience and at 18 my future
child God willing will be able to know
the name identity and last known
location of their father wow because you
reunited with does that person want to
be found yes that's part of what I paid
extra for yeah
quite literally yeah you're also dating
again I heard your your dentist set you
up so this is [__] y'all be watching on
TV they just in there clapping it up for
single motherhood huh
she taking fertility drugs and oh now
she dating so this man gonna stick with
her while she pregnant with a sperm
donor his sperm worked perfectly fine
but then he supposed to marry her after
that oh yeah he's gonna have to be rich
too like this [__]
absolutely
these numbers your your kid is more
likely to go to prison your kid is more
likely to be homeless your kid is more
likely to be in a mental institution
your kid is more likely to run away from
home your kid is more likely to have bad
grades why do we act like
women do not need men why do we act like
children do not need a father and they
can just do it on their own we can't and
we have shown time and time again that
we can't
women can be great wives and mothers but
they cannot do it without being under
the authority of a man we fail at it
again and again and yet women are
choosing this imagine do you guys think
we would have the same reaction if a man
hired a surrogate
do you think they would have the same
clapping reaction that's so great but
it's interesting because the media and
women treat men as disposable and that
the guy commenting was absolutely right
imagine oh my gosh imagine dating a
woman
that is going through IVF instead of
just settling with an average guy it's
it's actually crazy like I it blows my
mind that this is on national TV that we
are clapping and as women we should be
pissed off that we are being pandered to
this is pandering you know what do women
need more than anything in a
relationship and from our fathers is
guidance
guidance because when we are not guided
we do [__] like this and like people
when I say men are superior
I mean it because like men just don't
get you're not gonna have a a room full
of men clapping for single fatherhood
you will not find that but this is this
is what we have
and it's not hating women it's not
misogyny to point out that this is
[__] this is absolute [__] and
the worst part is the kids are the ones
that are going to suffer and I don't
really care if you say the kid will be
fine in 20 years this next generation is
going to start talking
and it'll be interesting what they have
to say about a lot of you surrogacy is
selfish and it's not natural I cannot
stand all of these methods that are
trying to make you play God
gives you a time to have children
God gives you time of fertility
and God didn't invent birth control God
didn't invent Ivy like all of this [__]
is just you deciding
to play God and the funny thing is women
are so picky
that we're running out of sperm like the
sperm banks are are running out of like
sperm that they deem good enough so you
know as a redhead
I've always taken pride in the fact that
I have red hair I've always taken pride
in it I've always thought it was really
cool like less than two percent of the
population I actually think it's one
percent but less than one percent of the
population has my combination green eyes
red hair and I always thought that was
really cool growing up my mom would
always tell me how beautiful my red hair
I mean it's a little darker now but
especially when I was younger it was
really bright red and I I always loved
it and I was always really proud of this
but apparently women are not picking for
them for kids pull the pull the sperm
bank now the world's largest sperm bank
is saying thanks but no thanks to one
pool of potential donors people with red
hair the problem is given the choice the
majority of women would prefer a child
and a partner with the more commonly
found blonde or dark hair This Ginger
rejection comes as some geneticists
predict natural redheads could become
extinct within 100 years
ah will be extinct
wow
that's kind of sad but that's a crazy
thing it's like and then now with all
these unnatural methods it'll be really
interesting to see if like certain
traits are going to go extinct because
we can be so specific to the point like
I've heard they're even trying to figure
out how to like fix DNA sequences
so it
it's gonna be a bit tricky because it's
really borderlining on Eugenics even
sperm donations like you kind of get
what you get in the natural Mark in the
sexual Marketplace you know what I mean
like a five you know maybe
she doesn't get a five maybe she gets a
six or a seven but she still doesn't get
a nine or a ten but now it's like
the Eugen it's almost like trending
towards Eugenics where a very small
percentage of men will get to reproduce
it'll be interesting it'll be really
interesting to see how this turns out
now we have women that are really are
I would say genetic like masterpieces
almost maybe it's not the right word but
like like top genes right they're
they're stunningly beautiful like
absolutely stunning and great bodies
very friendly and nice but
they still are not exempt to being
modern women the culture like women are
so susceptible to propaganda the culture
just has really ruined us we have Sofia
Vergara we we covered last week she's
getting a divorce so this woman is 51
and twice divorced she's been ensnared
in a legal battle with another
ex-boyfriend that she never married
because she wanted to destroy the Frozen
embryos they've created via IVF
and he did it her most recent divorce is
allegedly because her ex wanted kids and
she didn't but hey she's partying in
Italy in a swimsuit this is exemplary of
what is wrong with Western Society
there's no shame in being single but the
very few people are being called to a
lifetime lifetime of singlehood no one
is called to a series of broken
marriages single doesn't look so great
when you're 70 and alone it's really
interesting because it's almost like we
live in like
a fake world because these women like
they get their faces Frozen and like
they get all these like natural stuff
where they don't look their age but
think about an average like 55 year old
woman that you know wearing a swimsuit
like this it's almost like we're living
in this La La Land like I'm sorry a 55
year old woman should not be moving like
a 25 year old woman this should not be
controversial I don't care if you're
single or married you're supposed to be
an example to the younger women
yet like I don't even wear swimsuits
like that and I'm half your age lady
like and this is the crazy thing it's
like we have all of these old ladies
living like they're 25 when they are not
and we have a society that pushes them
to live in this delusion when literally
this woman is at the end of her life you
know I mean she's gonna maybe make it to
like 70 75 80. and what is that what
does the end of life look like you know
and and I really believe women
really start to feel lonely when looks
start to fade because when your looks
start to fade you kind of start to see
who who loves you for you and not your
looks and I've heard this from older
women where like it's kind of like you
real you go through a phase where
like when your looks start to go you you
realize a lot of like
the guys around you are just you know
there for one thing I mean obviously
we're red pill but you know and but but
it's like
what is what does life look like
at 70 for her when her looks are
actually gone because I don't know
I I maybe she'll look good at 70. I
don't know
um but
you know maybe it's just the CH like
that's just a childless woman the wives
and the mothers are so much better
right right right okay so let's look at
this successful I can do it all woman
she has four children
with the top one percent guy she now has
a new boyfriend allegedly who is um also
a very high status wealthy individual
and
she really is a billionaire she's doing
it all Kim Kardashian Kim K
so Kim Kardashian was seen partying with
Tristan Thompson the ex of her sister
Chloe you know Chloe have an on again
off-again relationship so maybe they're
even still together I wouldn't even be
surprised this is the wives and the
mothers that we have on the market she
has four children at home and she's
choosing to spend her time partying with
Tristan Thompson
okay like this is this is craziness this
is delusion like
again you are not supposed to move in
your mid-40s the same way you do it 25
but we have wives and mothers that are
at the bars with their kids they're at
the clubs with their kids they're moving
like a woman that is 20 years younger
than them when you have kids you know
you're kind of supposed to put that away
you know ladies I'll even be nice I'll
give you a couple times a year
twice you're not a club but like you can
go you know do your whatever have fun
with your girlfriends but like you're
out partying
with
your sister's ex-boyfriend
is that really a good look as a family I
don't I don't know guys how is single
motherhood treating Kim Kardashian
how
is it going as well as she thought you
know as you guys know Kim Kardashian
divorced Kanye a billionaire musician
you know one of the most talented people
I would say creatives of all time
and she divorced him and put him on
child support even though she's she did
the Modern Woman thing she's got her
career going she's got everything set
and yet she still put them on child
support so let's pull the clip like he
tells me to burn his stuff he's like who
cares burn it I thought maybe the kids
would think it was so cool
so I kind of kept everything for the
kids
like all these College Dropout stuff
I'm gonna take some for North like I
could be going through something but if
we're riding to school and they want to
listen to their dad's music no matter
what we're going through no matter what
is being happening in the world like I
have to have that you know smile on my
face and blast his music and sing along
with my kids and act like nothing's
wrong you know what's interesting you
see how the cycle like continues
because Kim Kardashian is literally
doing exactly what her mom did I mean
she drove her second husband so crazy
that he became a chick you know what I
mean
but you see it's like you you see and I
see these type of chicks all the time
they're very type a very controlling and
they never want to give up control to a
man and so they always have to have
their backup plan and a lot of times
like socializing and being in higher
Society is more important than the kids
like I I see these type of women all the
time and you you see how she does think
that Kanye is a good father
yet yet she couldn't work it out with
him that's the crazy thing now she's out
partying she's out dating all these guys
and I just can't like I can't imagine
growing up like that growing up where my
mom is taking me to football games where
she's hitting on the athletes or my
mom's out partying with her friends like
you were supposed to move differently as
a mother kids do not need money it is
not about money kids do not need money
they need involved parents that is so
much more important than money yet our
society tells us that money
is superior to Parenting and you're
gonna see it you start to see the
you start to see what's happening to
North now and it's really sad where
she's like doing like you you just see
her like at eight years old having it
having a tick tock but you see like
North like getting borderline like
inappropriate on Tick Tock at at what 10
years old
12 years old and you see
you really can't run from yourself as a
mother because your traits will pass on
to the children if you don't deal with
them
because you know kids look up to you and
they they follow your example and it's
really sad what is gonna happen to the
girls growing up like that
um and it's gonna show how important it
is to have a father in their life but
you know
maybe I'm just crazy
the quality of the wives the women that
stay married is just great we have such
great women to learn from
um they totally know what a wife is
pull the clip for better for better for
worse for worse for richer for richer
for poor
or poorer
yeah yeah
uh we hit destinag about 20 times in
counseling
Bria made it very clear to Jonathan you
cannot be broke
laughing
laughing imagine if a guy they don't
have for thinner or for fatter but
imagine if we had the equivalent of that
what the guy saying for fatter everyone
would freak out but it's like perfectly
okay for a woman to like disagree with
her marriage vows and everyone's just
laughing like we just have this Society
where we are laughing at marriage
literally and it's very disrespectful to
people that believe in the sanctity of
marriage like that's in a church where
it's funny that she would be with her
husband through a hard time it's funny
to them
next on Pearl daily let's talk about how
women we just believe things now I'm not
saying feminine men don't believe things
too but I'm saying women we always go to
the extreme where you know we'll lead
these social movements and just believe
them like it's actually quite crazy so
one of these crazy social movements is
veganism and as you guys would probably
guess vegan activists women are just the
most reasonable the most
agreeable you know they really like they
just tell people to get their points
across and all they're doing is just
being very reasonable and nice so there
was a clip that came from a vegan
protest let's pull the clip
there are male vegan activists too
but it's the women that are that are
screaming it's so funny once you start
to like look at modern women as children
because like that's like a kid's temper
tantrum I heard a guy say once that
women stop maturing once they like hit a
certain age where they start to get
attention from men so it's like some
women that's 14 some women that's 17
some women that's 16.
um and you know once I saw this I really
couldn't unsee it and you know it was
funny
one time this is a Side Story my grandma
I went
um
when I was in high school I got in
trouble so my mom sent me to my
grandma's house in Wisconsin and it was
so funny because my grand my grandma was
a widow at this time and she took me to
this like karaoke bar and at the karaoke
bar it was like her and the other widows
it's very interesting men like die
typically younger or like at an early
age than women and so the women like
it's like a new dating scene in like the
60s and 70s it's very interesting
they'll be like dating someone and
they'll just like die like I'm like
they'll literally be going on a date and
they're like oh I dated him and then he
died but it was so interesting because
the way they would speak about the guys
I remember being like 16 and thinking
they sounded like high schoolers I
remember I remember having this thought
like they kind of talk like me and my
friends do
and
you know no no shade to Grandma you know
rest in peace loved my grandma but but
it's just kind of funny where I realized
I'm like women we really just
stay the same age like mentally for a
lifetime like men kind of grow and
mature you can you can definitely tell
the difference talking to a young man an
older man and you used to be able to
tell the difference talking to a young
woman and an older woman but it's so
interesting because like guys this whole
theme of this today is like these
younger women act exactly like the older
women like it's just this delusion where
okay if I pretended to be A different
race people would think I was crazy like
they would think I was insane
um if I pretend to be a different gender
I mean some people don't think you're
crazy but like that's a small like most
people think you're kind of crazy right
if you're really trans and pretending to
be a different gender
but old women pretending to be young
women is socially acceptable why is it
okay for a 45 year old woman to pretend
to be a 25 year old woman but it would
be crazy if me a 26 year old woman
pretended to be a baby wouldn't that be
crazy like if I started saying goo goo
gaga but for some reason these older
women can dress like younger women
these older women can
move like younger women go to the clubs
with younger women date
men that are like 20 years younger than
them
um treat their kids as accessories
that's the other thing I realized so
many women want to have the kid not
because they love the kid not because
they want to be a wife and a mother and
a helpmate to a man but because
they want like an accessory for
Instagram
I swear I swear I believe this like
Instagram has brainwashed us so much
that we almost like live our lives for
Instagram and you'll see especially
tradcon women they'll uh they'll get
married and their husband almost becomes
like a prop for their brand and same
with their kids it's like they almost
like don't get married and have kids
because they want to and they like love
their family it just becomes like part
of the brand and we almost have a
society that's like moving and making
decisions for Instagram because
everything's so women-led so like women
are leading families women are making
purchasing decisions women have all the
voting power but it's so interesting
because women are living for Instagram
and making decisions for Instagram you
see women taking vacations for Instagram
you see women getting married for
Instagram you see women having children
for Instagram you see women going to
clubs being a part of social events for
Instagram like we used to have a
community we used to build community and
we would do it for fulfillment but now
it's literally for Instagram
but it's like weird we have this whole
society like
I don't know in history people would
kind of do what made sense for society
and you wonder why we have all these
like
I don't know this craziness all these
like mental health issues like you know
millionaire men cucking out their wife
you wonder why we have all these women
that have it made and then they think
they can do better like
it's so interesting because we always
talk about the men's porn addiction but
we never talk about the women's social
media addiction and as women we are like
so addicted to social media that we are
literally running Society based on
social media we're making decisions for
society based on social media and we
should be pissed off that the men are
lying to us that other women are lying
to us that older women are lying to us
and the media and companies are lying to
us to take our money because that's all
they care about they don't care about
the family They Don't Care About Us all
they want to do is make money off of us
and it's really like a sad way that
society's going now a lot of people want
to come at me but it's like don't shoot
the messenger I'm not blind and this
isn't just a small percentage of women I
I would say probably the majority of
women are addicted to social media and
we could talk about the men's porn
addiction right I'm not saying that
doesn't exist but I don't think men are
making life decisions based on porn
but women are making life decisions
based on what social media says and
they're worried more about the opinion
of social media than the opinion of
their husband
they're worried more about the like
think about that they're worried more
about the opinion of social media
than their husband but maybe I'm crazy
right sorry I ended every time maybe I
am just cherry picking and you know the
women are of great quality
um with our head on straight you know
and I actually I wanted to add one thing
women crave more than anything guidance
and I think that's like you know what
does a child need growing up guidance
what do women need we need guidance and
I know it's like people will say that's
offensive to like refer to women as
children but guys like come on look at
look at us
look at what we do when we have no
guidance so when they take the father
out of the home then you have us
believing in all these stupid social
movements you have us living our lives
for Instagram we condition men to think
that they are dumber than us to think
that they have no say and to think that
they should not guide us when they
absolutely should women we need guidance
because we're emotional we process
things with our emotion we we just we
get all amped up and stressed out like
men are a lot more calm they're a lot
more problem solved they're a lot more
problem solving oriented and that's
really what we're seeing a lack of when
you take the fathers out of the home is
guidance young men need it but
especially the difference is young men
get to a point where they can think for
themselves young women
I promise to God we do not think for
ourselves you might think you think for
yourself
you do not we can be so programmed by
Propaganda and the media we're just
different and it's not a bad thing guys
like in in history this is how we would
survive
you had to you had to adapt to the group
in order to survive but the problem is
the media companies have taken what used
to help us survive and weaponized it so
that we literally are destroying the
family structure
so I mean let me know what you guys
think in the comments maybe I'm just
crazy I just hate women big misogynist
you know like Adam 22 says misogynist
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time